Hello! And welcome to week three!
It's time to talk about distributed team management.
So before we get into all that good stuff; let's just talk about what's going on this
week.
So we're going to talk about various things this week;
many of the techniques we talk about are just as valuable for centralized team management
or co-located team management.
Although many of them are *particularly* valuable in distributed settings.
I'm going to tell you as much as I can to connect them to work we've been doing in a
distributed framework, such as the MOOC, and all the stuff with AgileVentures.
Some of what we'll talk about this week is still reviewing some topics that you'll know
already from having taken the ESaaS MOOC.
It might have been a while since you went through the MOOC so a little refresher shouldn't
hurt.
Also you'll be explaining many of these things to the students.
The students will have questions about these, so it's good to go over them again.
However we do have new material that's not in the 169 MOOC and the undercurrent here
is really all about managing Distributed teams.
In particular it's about how we're managing the volunteer nonprofit distributed teams
through AgileVentures.
Other people have been running distributed teams in one form or another for a lot longer
than we have;
so we don't claim to be the world's foremost experts on this.
Nonetheless we're got several years of experience with making distributed teams work.
The MOOC's coverage of software engineering in the cloud and working with teams does stress
the importance of teamwork.
But unfortunately the online MOOC doesn't have the equivalent of the team projects they
do at UC Berkeley.
However that's going to change with the introduction of 169 part 3 MOOC projects class; exciting
stuff!
In the meantime let me give you a bit more of an overview about what we've got coming
up in the next few videos.
So we're going to talk about Agile, particularly distributed Agile.
We're going to talk about Scrum, with a bit of a reference to distributed Scrum; where
I think Scrum works particularly well.
We're also going to talk about distributed management tools like Pivotal Tracker and
friends.
We'll talk about pair programming, remote pair programming, and other collaborative
patterns.
We've got a lot of materials this week; even more so than last week.
We've got extra videos from other sources; for example for Pivotal Tracker we've got
introductory videos provided by Pivotal Labs.
For the pair programming as well as me evangelizing and waxing lyrical;
we've also got various links to other resources and embedded videos from other speakers on
pair programming.
I think there is probably more material there, than you could reasonably cover in one week.
Don't feel that you have to cover all of it.
I think if at a minimum you just watch the main lectures from me, and then you can dip
in to the other ones as appropriate.
Next we'll move on to GitHub pong and the mechanics of how to do that.
Then finally we'll talk about GitHub for teams and this is super useful stuff, that is pull
requests, merging, cherry-picking and so on.
I apologize in advance if our coverage doesn't do justice to just how powerful and how useful
these techniques are,
but we have got me doing a live pull-request and associated merge in the actual video,
which I hope gives you a flavour for it all.
Again I wish I had had time to re-record all the videos.
I've settled for adding transcripts to all of them that I hope will suffice for the time
being.
I must say that any deficiency in the materials and recordings is down to me personally.
I'm hugely indebted to the full AgileVentures team who've worked behind the scenes to get
all these slides and quizzes and everything sorted.
Like open source software I think this course is incrementally moving in the right direction.
I'm hoping that what comes through is the wonderful time we're having in AgileVentures
collaborating online; managing our distributed team.
We very much hope that our experiences can help you in your journey.
So please, if you find anything that you'd like different in this course do let us know;
and feel free to get involved to help us improve it.
All the people, the entire AgileVentures team, are all people who've graduated from the 169
MOOC, just like yourselves.
They're just folks interested in the topic material and all working to keep learning
more about how to succeed as software engineers and as a distributed team.
I look forward to continue seeing you in the chat, where we've got some great discussions
going on relating to last week's assignment.
Alright, bye for now.